Donald Trump's new chief of staff could
not be more different than the President
himself whereas Trump has presided over
a White House that has been roiled by
chaos the problem with this is that
we've seen changing narratives disorder
you can't make up what's going on and
backstabbing
he's a showboat he's a glance stander
General John Kelly is known for his
insistence on discipline order and a
stable chain of command while Trump has
never served in the military he claims
to have great respect for the generals
and Kelly fits the bill he's a retired
four-star general with a decorated 42
year military career
Kelly's challenge is not only to bring
order to the White House but to help
push Trump's agenda through an unruly
Republican Congress that has already
defied the President on big issues like
health care this is how a career soldier
found himself the gatekeeper to the most
disorderly white house in modern history
John Francis Kelly was born on may 11th
1950 in Boston Massachusetts into an
Irish Catholic family at 16 he
hitchhiked and hopped trains across
America until he joined the Merchant
Marines then in 1970 he enlisted in the
US Marine Corps seeking higher education
he obtained a bachelor's degree from the
University of Massachusetts and a
master's of science and national
security studies from Georgetown after
rising through the ranks of the military
Kelley became a four-star general
eventually becoming head of the u.s.
Southern Command in 2012
perhaps his strongest suit is both his
leadership skills and the perception of
the leadership skills that's Margaret
Allen on the White House correspondent
for Bloomberg and I cover President
Donald J Trump on January 20th 2017
Trump tapped Kelly as Secretary of
Homeland Security in those very early
months of the Trump administration in
general Kelly helped President Trump
carry out and to defend his immigration
policies with the travel ban and with
the president's now infamous tweet
accusing President Obama of having
tapped in that Trump power the president
out of state said that he's got his
reasons and so President Trump came to
see general Kelly as supportive
after leading the department for six
months his tenure was cut short
John Kelly was announced on a Friday in
the middle of a rainstorm John Kelly
will do a fantastic job his first day on
the job with Monday morning empathise
Karen Ritchie was out it was all
happened really in the blink of an eye
the message that he sent by dismissing
Anthony strategy so quickly on day one
was unmistakable to everybody that's why
while keeping strict order and control
in the White House is one of the main
responsibilities of the chief staff it
remains to be seen if Kelly has the
political acumen to navigate the murky
partisan waters of DC politics
unlike previous chiefs of staff Kelly
has no experience playing politics and
has admitted to having little patience
for Capitol Hill if lawmakers not like
the laws that we are sworn to enforce
then they should have the courage and
the skill to change those laws otherwise
they should shut up and support the men
and women on the front lines it's only
six months is but it's been a very rocky
six months no no next question his job
to calm the waters to get the President
and Congress working together so that he
can execute the president's mission now
his reputation thus far is being sort of
a versatile process but look that hasn't
been his job until now general Kelly
will go down in terms of the position of
chief of staff one of the great ever
will Kelly be the first staff member to
rein in and tame the Trump White House
or will he be pushed out or resigned
like so many before him whether they can
actually coexist and provide sort of a
yin and the yang to one another it's
really the question to be determined the
answer to that question will probably
hold a key to how successful John Kelly
could be
[Music]
you